Harriet
Hey Harriet
Oh Harriet
Harriet
Harriet M. Welsch
I grew up with Harriet.
I was obsessed with her.
I have the great honor of playing Harriet M. Welsch.
And she’s so unapologetically herself
I’m glad I’m not perfect. I’d be bored to death.
Harriet is kind of all of us in a way.
Like nobody’s perfect; we’re all doing our best;
I hope people love her for that.
Woo hoo.
Huh.
Harriet! Watch where you’re going!
Ole Golly is Harriet’s nanny.
They have a very close relationship.
She's very much a mentor.
Remember, life is a struggle and a good spy never quits.
Ole Golly definitely allows Harriet to be who she is
and really encourages her and her passion.
Harriet wants to be a writer - more than anything in the world.
She doesn’t leave a room without her composition book at her side.
Ole Golly always told Harriet that in order to be a writer
you have to know everything.
And to know everything…
...you’ve got to see everything.
...and to see everything…
...you’ve got to be a spy.
Lacey plays Marion Hawthorne
who is the enemy of Harriet.
I love getting to play Marion because
she’s really fun to play.
She’s really funny.
Need I say more?
Marion Hawthorne is Harriet’s frenemy,
the character you really want to not like her,
but Lacey in this role was
adorable.
You act like you don’t like me, Harriet,
but I know your dark little secret:
You want to be me.
Ugh!
What is great about this series is
that it is a Valentine to the book.
It’s as if the characters walked out of the book
and came onto the screen.
I read Harriet the Spy as a kid
and I remember just loving her personality.
There’s no one like you Harriet M. Welsch.
And there probably never will be.
When I was eight years old reading the book
for the first time and Harriet was sort of a beacon of hope,
of like if she can get through all that,
I’m going to be ok.
Between her self esteem, her confidence,
she was such a role model to me.
Harriet was the ultimate outsider
but also who was unafraid to be so.
And we’re doing it for one thing:
freedom!
I was so excited when I found out
that Henson was making Harriet the Spy.
They have a legendary history of bringing complex,
very beautiful stories for young people specifically to life.
They’re great storytellers.
A lot of the people who work there
I think are little mini Harriets themselves.
Whoa!
[laugh]
So our Harriet The Spy takes place
where the original took place which is
1960s in New York City.
The show has this retro feel and I think,
in watching it you’ll feel like
you’ve kind of been transported back there.
New York City is full of opportunities to learn things.
It also looks beautiful.
It’s an animated world that looks amazing.
It’s so vibrant and the city’s buzzing
and Harriet gets to run around New York -
it’s almost like her playground.
It’s was a time when kids were allowed
to have a little bit more free agency.
We didn’t feel as shy about letting Harriet
roam the streets of New York City,
hopping on subways and figuring out her adventures in the city.
Hey watch where
you’re going kid!
- Ow!
I think it’s incredibly important for kids
to follow Harriet’s lead and be curious about the world.
And I think anyone at any age will enjoy
going on Harriet’s adventures with her
because she’s always looking for the lesson,
she’s always trying to better herself
and know everything and you get to know everything
with her and I think that’s really exciting.
With the future, there’s so much possibility.
But if you live in the now
you can make it something better.